[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 24 juin une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
débute sur tv 78 bienvenue dans ce
journal voici les titres
l'épisode d'intenses chaleurs qui
commence et va se poursuivre dans les
prochains jours le préfet des yvelines a
activé le niveau trois sur quatre est du
plan canicule le thermomètre va frôler
les 40 degrés l'une des conséquences le
brevet des collèges est reportée en
juillet le numérique au service des
médecins et patients à l'hôpital virtuel
va voir le jour à saint quentin en
yvelines c'est un projet mené par l'ue
vs qu lancé officiellement ce matin à
lui à faire santé simone veil à montigny
le bretonneux
et puis le document a été signé le 28
juin 1919 le traité de versailles a 100
ans signée entre les alliés et
l'allemagne suite à la première guerre
mondiale et nous lui consacrons cette
semaine une série de reportages
elle nous parlerons aussi tout à l'heure
d'une association yvelinoise le lien qui
fête cette année ses 30 ans
les thermomètres qui vont grimper très
haut cette semaine dans les yvelines
c'était déjà le cas ce matin vous le
voyez à montigny le bretonneux 27 degrés
affichés dès 11h le préfet a décidé
d'activer le niveau 3 sur 4 du plan
canicule dans le département ce niveau
engage la mise en place d'actions de
prévention et de communication par les
services publics certains en tout cas
chercher à des points de fraîcheur comme
dans le parc des sources de la bièvre à
aiguille en cours les températures qui
vont continuer d'augmenter tout au long
de la semaine on sera au bien au delà
des 30 degrés 31° demain à saint quentin
en yvelines 20 le matin à 20 degrés le
matin ça sera 31° à demain après midi à
saint quentin en yvelines 34 mercredi et
vendredi est la journée la plus chaude
est prévue pour jeudi avec un mercure à
36 degrés la nuit le thermomètre ne
devrait pas descendre en dessous des 20
degrés et c'est l'une des conséquences
de cette canicule
report du brevet des collèges annonce
cet après-midi du ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer est prévue ce jeudi et vendredi
pour les élèves de 3e l'examen est
finalement reportée au 1er et 2 juillet
et du côté des yvelinois comment se
prépare-t-on à cet épisode caniculaire
océane bazire et audrey chaillou sont
allés poser la question ce matin comme
je le fais à chaque fois c'est à dire
commencer par fermer les volets ça fait
déjà plusieurs jours que je les ferme
et puis essayer effectivement de
profiter des endroits un peu frais les
vomis thater voir beaucoup ça on nous le
dit à longueur de journée donc je pense
qu'on a compris quand même l'impression
qu'on prend tout le monde pour des
imbéciles mais je crois qu'on a compris
je subis un peu mais je bois je bois
beaucoup d'eau j'essaie de ne pas trop
m'activer
je gère ouais ça va arriver à gérer
j'ouvre j'ouvre grand la nuit est
effectivement
dès que le soleil commence à se
rapprocher à chauffer un peu je ferme
les volets et les fenêtres de la maison
j'allume le ventilateur et voilà
tellement suivi de l'algérie alors j'ai
l'habitude avec la chaleur et aux mais
bon il faut boire c'est l'essentiel pour
affaire pour avoir géré la journée et
tout mais bon tout ça va il faut juste
pas sortir trop sites à paris c'est à
rien à faire dehors peut pas sortir
c'est tout il faut bien aérien de la
maison c'est tout en m'appuyant léger
rebond je pense et en me prenant
probablement avec une bouteille d'eau
fermé les volets d'éviter de laisser
entre spies smith alors bon ou mauvais
réflexes ont fait le point avec vous
marylène iapichino bonsoir pensa de la
rédaction de tv 78 quels sont les bons
conseils pour survivre à cette canicule
alors tout d'abord grégory un réflexe
récent que vous apportez un verre d'eau
merci marc hillel parce qu'il faut avant
tout s'hydrater et ce tout au long de la
journée
en plus de vous accompagner d'une
bouteille d'eau vous pouvez privilégier
les aliments riches en eau tels que nos
fruits et légumes de saison
le melon la tomate la pastèque vous les
connaissez le ministère de la santé
diffuse des campagnes de prévention et
vous rappelle entre autres d'éviter les
efforts physiques et les sorties aux
heures les plus chaudes
pensez également à prendre des nouvelles
de vos proches surtout les plus fragiles
faire attention à son voisinage se fait
aussi partie des bonnes des bonnes
résolutions c'est à dire de permettre si
vous êtes au courant qu'une vieille dame
habite au 6e étage de votre immeuble
qu'elle est seule allée la voir et lui
rendre visite sachez si tout va bien et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est aussi de
l'appréhension
alors sachez que les personnes âgées
handicapées ou fragiles et isolées
peuvent s'inscrire sur une liste mise à
disposition à chaque mairie afin de
recevoir le soutien des bénévoles
un numéro d'information est également
mise en place il s'affiche en bas de
votre écran
l'appel est gratuit entre 9h et 19h
depuis un poste fixe donc quelques
conseils est ce que vous avez aussi des
suggestions pour se mettre au frais
marylène alors tout d'abord essayer le
plus possible de maintenir votre
logement frais en laissant les volets
fermés
rafraîchissez-vous et ventilés vous
le bon réflexe peut-être de se rendre
dans des lieux climatisés comme le
cinéma ou le centre commercial
si vous souhaitez rester en extérieur
pensée et jeux d'eau l'espace aquatique
de l'île de loisirs a ouvert ses portes
pour la saison depuis le 30 mai et le
centre aquatique du lac de montigny le
bretonneux a décidé de repousser ces
travaux de vidange des passants pour
permettre aux habitants de venir se
rafraîchir pensait températures
exceptionnelles
enfin n'oubliez pas les endroits
ombragés comme les forêts l'espace
rambouillet par exemple est ouvert du
mardi au vendredi de 9h30 à 18h et de 10
heures à 19 heures le week-end
merci marylène pour tous ces éléments
voilà ce qu'on pouvait vous dire
aujourd'hui sur cet épisode caniculaire
dont les yvelines est le reste de
l'actualité en bref ont voté ce dimanche
à vernouillet pour une élection
municipale partielle rendue nécessaire
après des démissions en cascade au sein
du conseil de mer du conseil en mai le
maire sortant udi pascal collado est
arrivé largement en tête à l'issue du
premier tour 44 4% et des voix et devant
l'ancien maire socialiste marie hélène
lopez jollivet en lice sous l'étiquette
de la république en marge qui récoltent
elles 24,4 pour cent des suffrages la
liste divers droite de l'ancien adjoint
jean yves denis et celle sans étiquette
de jean pierre grenier obtiennent
respectivement des scores de 16 7% et
14,3 pour cent ses quatre listes sont en
position de se maintenir pour le second
tour prévu dimanche prochain
la plainte déposée contre l'inra à jouy
en josas une ancienne chercheuse
employés dans l'unité de recherche de
2009 à 2012 est décédé lundi dernier ait
des suites de creutzfeldt-jakob elle
travaillait sur des maladies dites à
prions dont fait partie cette pathologie
selon l'inra cette jeune femme de 33 ans
avait subi un accident de service lors
d'une expérimentation en laboratoire à
la famille de la victime dénonce des
manquements à la sécurité elle a porté
plainte pour homicide involontaire toute
la vérité sera faite assure de son côté
le site de jouy en josas et des
consultations en télémédecine ou encore
des formations via simulateur un hôpital
virtuel va voir le jour à saint quentin
en yvelines
le lancement du projet avait lieu ce
matin à lui vs qu objectif affiché que
le numérique assiste davantage médecins
et patients les précisions de maryland
chine aux professionnels de santé
chercheurs et élus de l'agglomération se
sont réunis au sein de l'ufr santé de
l'université saint quentin en yvelines
pour le lancement d'un projet imaginé
depuis déjà deux ans la création d'un
hôpital virtuel à l'hôpital virtuel
savent être d'abord un bâtiment c'est du
solide et à l'intérieur va m on va
reconstruire fait à l'hôpital mais avec
tout virtuel c'est à dire des mannequins
pour la simulation
on va avoir des salles de chirurgie des
salles d'obstétrique des salles de
pédiatrie des salles de consultation
c'est un lieu une plateforme de
simulation de haut niveau trois axes
stratégiques sont imaginer un
développement de l'offre de soins avec
notamment la télémédecine un
renforcement de la formation mais
également la création d'un living lab
pour encourager la recherche
il a besoin de réinventer le chu il ya
besoin de réinventer la place du chu
dans les territoires parce que voilà
c'est pas un scoop de dire que la
majorité de nos citoyennes de
concitoyens se plaignent de difficultés
d'accès aux soins d'accès à la
prévention d'accès à l'éducation en
matière de santé et bien là cet espace
cette expérimentation du chu de demain a
pour objectif pour ambition de répondre
à ces besoins de la population
le bâtiment de 5000 m² s'inscrit dans le
contrat local de santé de saint quentin
en yvelines l'agglomération apporte le
foncier et se montre actrice pour
trouver les financements
cet hôpital virtuelle dans le cadre de
ce contrat local de sécurité au même
titre que nous sommes à la pointe pour
tout ce qui concerne le développement
numérique au même type nous soyons nous
espérons et nous serons à la pointe au
niveau de tout ce qui est cybersécurité
voilà c'est un événement de pointe dans
lequel notre territoire souhaite
s'inscrire dans les mois et les années à
venir
un sachet du futur pour pallier
l'absence de centres hospitaliers
universitaires dans les yvelines à
l'heure actuelle objectif rêvée pour le
doyen de l'ufr santé une ouverture pour
les jeux olympiques de 2024
après les premières ébauches de mars la
direction académique des yvelines a
dévoilé la seconde version de sa carte
scolaire pour la rentrée en école
maternelle et primaire
quand deux classes ouvriront dès
septembre 30 classes au contraire
fermeront a justement fait en raison
d'une baisse des effectifs en maternelle
et d'une augmentation en élémentaire le
dispositif du dédoublement de classes
sera également poursuivie et dans le
réseau d'éducation prioritaire en tout
ce sont 480 8 classes qui seront à des
doublés à la rentrée prochaine deux
invités m'ont rejoint au plateau c'est
christine baudelaire et pierre-jean
blard bonsoir alors soit vous êtes
respectivement directrice générale et
président de l'association yvelinoise le
lien elle va fêter ses 30 ans une
journée de célébration est prévue ce
jeudi 27 juin au domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles donc trente ans
pour cette association
ça fait trente ans qu'elle travaille
dans l'ombre en tout cas elle se fait
discrète cette association qui enjambe
la wii discrétion discrétion peut être
un peu historique
c'est une association dont l'idée a
germé dans l'esprit de d'élus
départementaux il ya 30 ans quand on ce
docteur ducret qui était le le maire de
maisons laffitte à l'époque il ya dix
finalement côté des dispositifs de
l'état qu'il était en bonne
décentralisation sociale en 1983 on
pourrait peut-être confié à une démarche
associative
si dense et a concédé par te mentale
quelque chose à une mission qui
passerait par le logement 16 ans qui
sont dans la rue et qu'on replace très
rapidement dans le système d'urgence
c'est lui qui est à l'origine de ça et
puis c'est une politique continue et
discrète mais je pense efficace il dure
depuis trente ans et c'est une certitude
c'est que l'insertion se fait par le
logement social pourquoi le logement at
il une une place si importante
je pense que le logement c'est la
première sécurité pour une personne
quand on rentre dans sa vie d'adulte on
a besoin d'un toit quand on prévoit
aussi son grand âge on pense encore un
autre type de toit tout le long de la
vie on a besoin d'un toit c'est la
première des sécurités 107 sécurité là
on peut pas se projeter on peut pas
faire de projets il n'y a pas de vie de
famille c'est très difficile de trouver
un emploi sans logement on n'est rien on
n'a même pas d'identité et commander ce
qu'on peut exercer sa vie de citoyen
quand jean n'a pas d' adresse donc on
sait c'est la première c'est vraiment la
première démarche à franchir pour
permettre à quelqu'un de repartir mais
parce que le lien accompagne les
personnes les familles en situation de
précarité lors de leur entrée dans un
logement comment se déroule cet
accompagnement alors cette que christine
n'entrera pas dans le détail très
rapidement qu'est ce qui vous a fait que
les quatre mesures essentielles quatre
actions quatre métiers on dit sont
d'abord le bail glissant ensuite des
mesures d'accompagnement par le jouant
tous différents différentes formes sur
plusieurs métiers et enfin l'accueil des
mineurs non accompagnés
[Musique]
que l'on évoqué on évoquera tout à
l'heure l'idée c'est qu'effectivement
donner un toit à quelque 1 600 précarité
doit être complétée par une
accompagnement social compagnon social
très structuré très exigeant mais dont
l'objectif est de donner l'autonomie à
la personne et l'autonomie du logement
avec notamment ce bail glissant cette
idée juridiquement très curieuse au
départ et qui durant 18 mois dans un
premier temps l'idée voilà c'est pas qui
est cet accompagnement tout au long
d'une vie c'est devenez finalement un
élan et surtout pas accompagné toute une
vie redonner à la personne l'envi l'envi
d'agir pour elle lui montrer qu'elle en
a les capacités c'est veut redonner
confiance en elle quand on est dans la
pire des difficultés je crois que
l'estimé de soi est très atteinte
on ne croit plus en soit on ne croit
plus qu'on est compétent et le système
dead as a malheureusement un peu de je
dirais d'effets pervers c'est que plus
on demande de l'aide et plus on a le
sentiment qu'on est disqualifié et qu'on
est incompétent il faut inverser la
mécanique donc un toit première des
sécurités un accompagnement pour coacher
quelque part rendre de nouveau la
confiance à la personne faire un plan
d'intervention qui permet à la personne
d' aller par étape vers un redressement
de sa situation jusqu'à ce qu'elle
puisse mesurer qu'effectivement le
chemin parcouru
c'est elle qui l'a vraiment parcouru et
c'est elle aujourd'hui qui peut être
fier de ses résultats et la voilà elle
et elle reprend sa vie en main on se
retire et puis l'objectif est accompli
c'est quelque chose qui guide
je dirais tout la pratique qu'on a
développé depuis ces trente ans c'est
que 200 travailleurs sociaux qui
oeuvrent au quotidien alors la dette va
complètement ne sont pas tous
travailleurs sociaux on avait plus de
plusieurs métiers ou lien on est
vraiment dans une vraie
pluridisciplinarité
c'est cette richesse là qui fait que
justement on approche un peu dans leur
transversalité les situations et puis je
crois aussi qu lien on a la culture du
partenariat
quand on est une association qui doivent
oeuvrer dans une prise en charge globale
les personnes que nous rencontrons des
problèmes de santé elles ont des
problèmes d'insertion il ya beaucoup de
difficultés il faut aussi savoir les
orienter
pouvoir être un peu source de conseils
et de liens avec d'autres partenaires
qui dans leur champ de métier
apporteront une complémentarité et c'est
tout ça qui fait qu'à un moment donné la
personne va pouvoir se remettre en selle
et puis j'en veux leur parler aussi de
l'accompagnement des mineurs non
accompagnés qui viennent y viennent
d'afrique d'inde du pakistan ils sont
220 sur le territoire des yvelines alors
nous en nous n'aurions 220 220 d'entre
eux ils sont peut-être un peu plus mais
il ya des dix on dénombre plafond
affecté par département une mesure que
nous avons que le conseil départemental
nous a demandé de prendre en charge il y
a bientôt quatre ans à partir de
justement le constat que ce que pouvait
apporter le lien passe en bas un
logement de ces personnes qui sont bien
évidemment à la rue et qui sont dans des
situations extrêmes était une solution
transposable ça fonctionne avec un
concept que on peut le dire on a
inventée de a à z et qui aujourd'hui
commence à être copiée dans d'autres
départements
mais ça ça fait partie de l'actualité de
l'association elle va étendre son champ
d'action puisqu'elle va travailler aussi
dans le département des hauts-de-seine
tout à fait un accueil dans des comptes
des départements ont dû se parler sur le
sujet je pense qu'il porte sur d'autres
sujets mais le modèle du lien va être et
temps et déployé sur le 92 dans le cadre
d'abord l'expérimentation et d'un appel
à projet qui est en cours là aussi pour
développé par le logement cet
accompagnement d'un public très
différent celui là ce sont des gens que
vous lisiez entre 14 et 18 ans maximum
c'était un accompagnement donc
transitoire provisoire de
personnalisation très faible en termes
de culture complètement différente de
langage de mode sociaux ne sont pas des
délinquants
ce sont des personnes malheureusement
garçons et filles qui ont vécu des
drames un comparable à ce qu'on peut
imaginer la sueur en métropole et qu'il
s'agit de faire rebondir que cet
accompagnement en 20 secondes on peut
lui souhaiter quoi à votre association
encore jeudi belles années je pense
qu'on a passé le cap des 30 ans c'est un
bel âge de vie on va avec beaucoup de
sérénité vers nos 40 ans et il paraît
que ça sera encore un plus bel âge on
dit que 40 ans c'est un âge où on vit
tous ses rêves donc on part dans la
confiance
très rapidement nous sommes une
entreprise sociale et donc on pense pas
forcément à la culture encore que frank
sinatra disait que souhaites tu m'as la
question posée que souhaites-tu pour
autant anniversaire la réponse était un
autre anniversaire à notre anniversaire
d'entrepreneur social dans ce domaine et
on vous souhaite bon anniversaire merci
pierre jean blair merci christine
baudelaire d'être passé sur ce plateau
toutes les informations sur cette
association a retrouvé un sur le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran à partir
du 27 juin la date d'anniversaire qui
sera célébrée donc au domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles
c'est le dossier de la rédaction ce
vendredi ce sera le centenaire du traité
de versailles signé dans la célèbre
galerie à des glaces le 28 juin 1919
après la première guerre mondiale
premier focus ce soir sur certains
documents conservés par les archives
départementales photos affiches sont
décryptés par un historien c'est au
micro de nicolas d'andré ce jour fera
date dans l'histoire le 28 juin 1919
congrès de la paix au château de
versailles
après la défaite des allemands en 1918
les alliés organise la paix c'est le
traité de versailles
il ya le souci de se présenter comme
vrai homme d'état
souvent l'audience et endurance et sont
seulement
oui il ya beaucoup de militaires sur la
photo on ne voit pas du tout sourire du
côté dé versailles et le maire de
l'époque henri simon lance un appel à
ses concitoyens néanmoins les édifices
publics seront pavoisés et illuminer les
habitants suivront certainement cet
exemple on parle quand même de paix
victorieuse comme on est lancé la
victoire peut pas être avec toi à partir
à certains et pas à d'autres
c'est aussi comme si on veut faire appel
au versailles et de se sentir quelque
peu victorieux
je dirais c'est après tout c'est le
maire qui vont bénéficier politiques
locales des chefs d'état y de nombreuses
délégations diplomatiques sont présentes
ce 28 juin 1919 un événement menée par
le président du conseil français georges
clemenceau et le président des états
unis woodrow wilson avec deux visions
différentes
globalement il y avait l'idée de rendre
ne manque plus sûr par la
démocratisation prémaman de rendement
plus sûr par la sécurité collective sont
six nations et trois grandes le mans
peut-être plus interdépendants il y
avait déjà l'idée de libre commerce
face à lui on à clemenceau qui lui il
croit plutôt à la realpolitik à la
realpolitik veut dire aux rapports de
force dont louis estime une paix durable
repose vraiment sur la force
force dissuasive autres documents
conservés par les archives
départementales les remarques des
allemands sur les conditions de la paix
ce qui a été ressenti le plus c'est un
diktat s'est imposé ce qu actes très
imposé de traiter le fait que les
allemands étaient totalement exclu tout
temps considéré comme un objet et
surtout qu'ils étaient considérés comme
moralement un coupable tout d abord bien
sûr s'opposer aux réparations ont perçu
la somme qu'ils devaient payer s était
pas possible de payer jusqu aux années
80 il sourit tout payé il ya des aspects
aussi cette limitation de l'armée
allemande au regard mais ne pouvait plus
avoir plus que sur miller mettra au
total plus d'une cinquantaine de
documents sont conservés aux archives
départementales en lien avec cet
événement des pièces achetées auprès de
particuliers
[Musique]
allez le sport à présent avec vous
michael et demi d'euro bonds soir dans
sa grille nous présentait bien sûr comme
tous les lundis les résultats sportifs
dans le département du vtt pour
commencer cette chronique
c'est une véritable tradition dans les
yvelines ce dimanche 23 juin à 9h30
précis 160 coureurs se sont réunis au
pied de la colline d'elancourt pour
participer à la 21e édition de la
revancharde une course de vtt qui s'est
tenue sous des températures estivales
cette année un tracé de 5,9 km a été
imaginé par les organisateurs sur le
futur site olympique et des compétitions
de vtt en 2024 on écoute l'un des
organisateurs niveau difficulté assez
élevé comme voilà après fo fo est assez
technique par endroit il ya un peu de
roullens il faut savoir faire du vtt
pendre je sais que voilà là où il
s'aventure avec leurs vélos moi je
descendrai je descendrai côté c'est sûr
il a bien boucler ses cinq tours nicolas
10 mai de gif-sur-yvette remporte cette
édition on écoute sa réaction eu beau
parmentier qui est parti
devant il y avait 20 à 30 secondes
d'avancé suite avec cédric chartier on
est un peu du tout les deux petit à
petit et voilà ensuite on a fait le
petit groupe de trois et ensuite bon on
s'est attaqué juste dans la fin la
dernière bosse en parallèle l'événement
a permis de récolter près de 2500 euros
en faveur des orphelins des sapeurs
pompiers
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition du football a présenté
quelle direction le club de football de
trappes l'annoncé tombée ce week-end en
assemblée général mustapha larfaoui a
décidé de quitter la structure après 16
années passées au club dont 14 à sa
présidence aux potentiels tête de liste
à la mairie de la commune il ne voudrait
pas mélanger les genres en écoute
justement la réaction de mustapha
larbaoui que l'on mélange le monde
associatif avec la politique
j'avais demandé aux éducateurs dans la
campagne et pourra durant les campagnes
au respect en dehors du champ politique
pour l'association est préservé tel sur
l'association au delà de la sphère
politique
donc nous l'a plutôt moi même tout
simplement mais rassurez-vous grégory
mustapha larfaoui a déjà annoncé qu'il
viendrait supporter ses désormais ex
joueur sur le terrain a dit rezaï
guessoum reste président du club
on termine par un hommage c'était à
magny les hameaux pour la sixième année
consécutive un tournoi amical en hommage
à l'ancien capitaine du club franck
klimko s'est déroulée samedi au stade
jacques anquetil au rendez vous a réuni
dix équipes venues de l'île de france
dont les clubs de jouy en josas et
montigny le bretonneux présent depuis
les débuts on écoute les réactions au
micro d'aurélie ans ça nous a pris un
peu de temps pour organiser le tournoi
mais ça fait on a mis quatre ans à peu
près avoir cette idée et du coup là ça
fait six ans qu'on pérennise le tournoi
et je pense que vu le monde qu'il ya
aujourd'hui et vu comment ça fonctionne
chaque année ça a l'air de ça à l'air de
bien marcher du court déjà c'est pour
rendre hommage je rende hommage à la
personne qu'on connaissait à francky mco
et
et revoir des amis qu'on voit pas tout
le temps est passé une super journée
ensoleillée en plus après la journée de
compétition c'est finalement fontenay le
fleury qui remporte le tournoi pour sa
première participation
merci à mikel pour ce tour d'horizon
plus d'actualité sportive bien sûr à
venir après ce journal votre émission le
7-8 sport comme tous les lundis sur tv
78 enfin le week-end avant le week end
même vendredi la musique était à
l'honneur l'honneur dans une centaine de
pays et de nombreuses manifestations se
sont déroulées aux quatre coins des
yvelines la ville de croissy sur seine
avait misé sur le folklore américain de
son côté mort pas à renouveler son
opération terrasse en musique ambiance
avec aurélie rond et michael et demi
d'euros du rock'n'roll à maurepas de la
conterie à croissy-sur-seine des
ambiances différentes pour célébrer le
début de l'été mais aussi la musique
avec un grand m
pour cette 38e édition de la fête de la
musique la ville de croissy sur seine a
permis au public de traverser
l'atlantique et de vivre à l'heure
américaine et découvrir notre pays
bon ça fait partie du raid américain
c'est de relier la musique américaine
avec sa fusée qui peut équipe
féminine de foot américain et croatie
les accueils à maurepas
la musique s'est invitée sur les
terrasses de plusieurs commerçants
au programme de la bonne humeur de la
convivialité et du rhum
[Applaudissements]
on est sur quelque chose aussi qui
rassemble les générations qui permet
aussi de sortir du travail de tous
d'avoir un bon moment ensemble
c'est de retrouver des groupes musicaux
différents
dans les quartiers et de s'y rendre
quand on veut jusqu'à tard le soir
[Musique]
c'est un bel événement pour faire la
fête justement ondes et on y découvre
des artistes
généralement il fait beau parce que
c'est le mois de juin donc annoncé super
sympa comme événement c'est un endroit
convivial où comme pas mal de gens on
peut s'amuser boire un p'tit coup voilà
les attentions avec l'alcool
évidemment si on conduit mais par contre
c'est super cette année encore plus de
120 pays à travers le monde ont fêté en
musique le prouve en souffrent de la
nuit mais voilà c'est la fin de 7,8
journal retrouvez nos reportages et
l'édition complète sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile td
60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]